this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they get episodes
of player watch listen early on edited
and AD free as well as the opportunity
to ask questions for any of the other
podcasts that I do and request certain
guests but mostly if you'd like to
support this very independent show that
has declined sponsorships for years now
check us out on patreon.com
so hello everyone usually we don't intro
the show at the start but it's gonna be
a beefy one today and I'm excited meaty
uh this is play watchlist and that's
Mike bipple he's a video game director
and that is our friend Rami Rami I
actually realized that I don't even know
how to introduce you at this point
right yeah I actually I actually have no
idea how to introduce myself either I'm
an independent game developer I've been
making games for about 15 years
I'm probably best known by Gamers for
Nuclear Throne uh Ridiculous Fishing
which is again about fishing with
machine guns some smaller indie games
from like 10 15 years ago super great
boxes of trousers by developers I'm
mostly known as the person who goes
around and tries to help developers
around the world get access to game
development resources so I'm kind of
like two different sites of the the coin
so I just kind of do all sorts of things
great I feel better I didn't know how to
describe it Austin we just started
recording welcome this is the most
professional this show I've ever been
uh Rami was uh just a pilot of
burgeoning uh emerging pilot and all the
rest of that feels like very kind of
peripheral
I I do enjoy flying airplanes a lot but
it's a it's a recent thing you're the
only person I know the cool thing you do
the only person I know who spent like 50
million hours in Microsoft flight
simulator and then was like time to
raise the bar right yeah wait is that
how that happened the graphics I mean so
when I was really really young I really
wanted to be a pilot I was the first
thing I ever wanted to be I wanted to be
a pilot because we would go to Egypt
where the rest of my family lives once a
year from the Netherlands so I would get
in the magic tube and then I would see
all the buttons at the front of the
magic tube and then I would get out of
the magic tube and then I would be in
Egypt so that was phenomenal to me and I
I wanted to be the people near the
buttons and then and then I got my
glasses at like age six of my dad being
Egyptian looked at me and went like well
there goes your dream of becoming a
pilot because the only way into being a
pilot in Egypt to feel the military and
the military doesn't it doesn't accept
Pilots with glasses because you're
getting shot at it if your glasses fall
off then you you're not going to be a
really good pilot so turns out that in
commercial Aviation and in civil
aviation that's not actually a thing
you know what
maybe my favorite was you I love that
playing flight simulator on a plane with
the actual like window open right next
to you that was my favorite little
glimpse into your psyche right that was
uh uh I flew from Montreal to the
Netherlands and then as we were taking
off I booted up the flight and flight
simulator and also took off
and then just checked how close it was
and it was terrifying like the stars
were correct wow and I was looking
outside I'm like I feel like that would
make me feel super impressive like you
know how VR you'll feel motion sick when
your body's intuition about motion
you're supposed to be experiencing isn't
mapping to what it's telling you and
that sort of thing I feel like the
slight inconsistencies between what
would be on screen and then the
otherwise very similar real world
ambient surroundings would make my brain
kind of
have a stroke think you're being
poisoned
yeah that's what causes the vomiting um
everyone that's Austin I want to use a
video game composer uh and what shows up
I had to because we're going to be
talking about Unity today but I was
child aggressively
um to ask you Austin of course from our
good friend Andy grush who harassed you
several times last night uh to ask you
about the guy that played at the
Hollywood Bowl last night please don't
spend 50 minutes answering this question
I'm aware of the risk
Andy called him the best musician alive
I heartily I would I was gonna say the
same thing I think he is fine
Jacob Collier
I think he is he is made of music you
know how like you know how in Phantom
Menace uh Qui-Gon says to Obi-Wan I
think Anakin was made by the force
um I think that is actually accurate
about Jacob Collier so I never even
heard of him until Andy said that he was
like
he was pretty Niche because that I'm
actually blown away that he could fill
the Hollywood Bowl because he's he's I
would I think of him as pretty Niche
because what he does
is so
superhumanly sophisticated and musically
complex it has it it not all of it is he
can do things that are incredibly simple
and just gorgeous and laid bare but he
has this heart of a jazz musician and he
has he has complete and total command
over music I mean he sings he plays a
thousand instruments and he'll do these
complex harmonies with himself or with
other singers like last night there was
seven and eight part harmonies with
singers where it gets so dense that I
just think there's just we live in a
world where there's very little
mainstream appeal to this kind of music
where Everything feels like he's
delighting and exploring like you know
how you'll watch a high level tennis
player or somebody where it just feels
like
gravity doesn't seem to apply anymore
they just they just the flick of a
finger and the ball will keep moving and
they're never that's how I feel
recording this podcast
uh Andy Andy by the way uh Andy grush is
one half of the Newton Brothers uh most
recently known for composing things like
midnight mass the upcoming full of the
House of Usher which I'm not technically
allowed to promote but have seen and
love posters composers uh forbidden in a
non-promotional way when's that coming
out of sag it's coming out on October
12th for your personal curiosity Mike
thank you that's true he is an atypical
composer because he was in every episode
of midnight mass as the church organ
player yeah he's also in it oh is that
right oh it's upcoming thing yeah which
like I always say is the best actor in
the show just to piss everyone else off
it's like Michael trubo and Sam Sloan
with Alice Knight but he said um and
Rahul and Rahul obviously uh he said
midnight mass I don't remember yes he
plays dolphin in the church I'm joking
uh Andy
um he said Jacob Collier is capable of
singing
uh in between
Keys like he's created micro keys
he didn't create it but he has such a
neutral
so what he's referring to is like Pluto
but in reverse the um the in the world
of music if you think about the fact
that all sound can be labeled with a
frequency so you know the a that an oboe
player Tunes the rest of the orchestra
to is at exactly 440 Hertz which we call
it a440.
um but if you think about it all sound
exists on this spectrum of wavelengths
it's so the the the 12 tone chromatic
system that is the basis of like the
Western kind of conception of music
is uh not an arbitrary but like a
historically evolved carving up of
the frequency spectrum where if you take
a440 and you go down to a220 exactly an
octave lower the 12 Steps in between
exist at very specific frequencies but
it makes sense if you think about it
intuitively that that that is just a
sort of obviously this is all obviously
if you think
it's points on a line where you're
putting little dots on that line but you
could theoretically do them any which
way there's why you have what we would
call Micro tonal music where people
start to say well what about the notes
in between those or what if we structure
the scale differently what's the
difference between even temperate and
mean tempered where maybe the distance
between those notes even within the same
12 notes the distance between them might
be subtly different and this is where
you start to get into Acoustics of
different types of instruments well can
I ask the ignorant question then which
is
what's what's the element of this that's
impressive then because obviously anyone
can be off most like anyone can hear
frequencies is it the Artistry of then
making that sound good when you are off
of the off-peace
that's a pretty good way to to kind of
cut to the chase because yeah if you if
you sing what's 9 10 if you swear well
no but no but that's but I I I I don't
actually want to belabor the point
because I am very curious all of your
comments on Unity but the um the idea of
micro tonality it's to a western ear
it's extremely easy for that to just
sound Out Of Tune because you might be
you know we measure the difference uh
the the distance between the notes on
the keyboard uh with what we call sense
like 100th of a half step like like
sense of a dollar
um and so from C to C sharp you know
you've got
so like
most people would need a computer to go
oh that's C sharp Plus
eight cents because you're talking about
a such a tiny fraction between the notes
and Jacob seems to just like I said he's
made of music there's no amount of
precision he can't keep up with it
literally not never mind that he plays
so many different instruments so he did
this Arrangement
um that of the classic Henry Mancini
song from Breakfast at Tiffany's Moon
River where I was he did this um like
two hour walkthrough of his arrangement
on on YouTube that I was watching a
couple years ago or a year ago whenever
it was and I remember hearing the kind
of Apex the big glorious climax of the
piece where it just sounded really
special and I I for the life of me I
couldn't figure out why and it turns out
it was because he wanted it to have a
certain quality where he goes the only
way I could achieve that is by being by
by peeking on the chord g half sharp
major
so he's landing on a key and there's
like a hundred parts all simultaneously
of different singing and whatnot that
are all perfectly in tune with each
other but if you were to play it up
against someone playing a G sharp it
would sound violently dissonant like one
of the these two is really wrong but he
gets there so smoothly and gradually you
don't even realize the trick he's
pulling on you which is why I didn't
clock it when I heard it you know before
it kind of analyzes the old history is
kind of sneaking that past the Western
Air it reminds me speaking it past a
composer right like yeah it reminds me
of um when you when you hit like hero
narrative like the hero's journey the
cliche story there's an argument there
was there used to be an argument that
they're also I'm gonna be Mike for a
second
and it's not the only story there's a
million different stories but it became
so popular that that was the only story
that we basically are now in a world
where for about 40 50 years most
especially American but most kind of
Western Cinema in general has been
telling that story and now there's an
argument that it's not that that story
is quintessentially human it's that we
have Generations now that that's the
only story they know how to receive so
if you don't hit the people strongly
Journey people think something's wrong
with storytelling people think
something's up people are like you've
missed the note there I'm expecting this
to fall exactly there right yeah and the
stories we celebrate now are arguably
much less diverse than they were before
and basically before Star Wars but now
the Artistry is in how much can you put
a bit of spin on that ball how much can
you my mixing so many metaphors how much
can you kind of play with the rules and
and get it past people something like
you know if you look like Nolan and how
much you know how love it he is by film
nerds a big part of that is that he is
structuring his movies in a way that
they're still basically following that
hero's journey but he nudges things
around enough and that's why it kind of
fits but arguably his films are much
less interesting story wise than the the
broad range of movies we had again
before 1977. anyway I'm sorry I just
thought there was an analogy there in
how you're talking about I feel that
um the uh the only other thing I would
add I was with a friend of mine who is a
genius in his own right guy named Mike
Miller at the concert last night I
thought you're gonna say Bethel
um sorry
genius thank you thank you thank you
thank you
um and uh the uh
Mike had a brilliant analogy because I
always found myself thinking thank you
what what Jacob does is so on a level
that
um it's hard to truly appreciate even as
a musical professional which is why I
always thought he was kind of Niche
because because it's sort of like to a
lot of people it probably just sounds
exhausting because he's just so
complicated in what he does you need a
level of literacy to spot what's going
on is what you're saying yeah but I'm
really wrong because you know it was
like 15 000 people there last night that
were off the hook for him like a total
Rock and he's an incredible performer so
energetic running back and forth and
back and forth playing all these
instruments where he'll start singing
and he'll be with one of his other
singers and run and sit at the piano and
just whip out this incredibly virtuosity
piano thing then jump over onto the
drums and he never stops moving so on a
basic superficial level it's just
exhilarating to watch but the point that
that the other mic made was he said
imagine a painter
that could see into like the X-ray
Spectrum or into the infrared spectrum
and what they would paint that we
wouldn't even know they were painting
because we physically cannot see it but
it exists that is essentially I thought
the best analogy I'd ever heard to Jacob
Collier it's like he just has access to
senses that most his color gamut is
broader than yours yeah and he says the
same thing that's that's nuts like
someone I'd never even heard of Austin
would you say that watching Jacob
Collier live had like the opposite
effect on you as watching what Unity did
this week Oh I thought you were going
for did you find that the audience kind
of really came together in a unified way
I thought that was going to be yeah you
should I should have done that damn
that's what I thought you guys it was
really good it was one of the best it
was one of the best uh shows I think
I've ever been to yeah well arguably and
sorry usual disclaimers this is all my
opinion I'm not breaking in the ndas by
anything I'm going to say please take
everything I say is a statement of my
personal opinion and not fact but what's
interesting here is that Unity have done
a similar thing where they've found a
new way to expand a Euler it's
incredibly impressive
they can see they can see layers of
agreements that we don't even remember
making it's incredible
um Rami could I have you just for people
who totally aren't familiar who clicked
on this because they're like What's this
Unity thing gamedevs are upset about
what is unity and why are people upset
all right so Unity is a game engine it's
it's the the programs that game
developers use to make games in unity is
one of the larger ones that's mostly
used by independent developers mobile
developers uh VR developers use use it a
bunch
um
and it has traditionally always been one
of the more accessible options it's
taught a lot in education a lot of
developers grow up with unity and a lot
of the um indie games that you might
have heard of and love are also in built
in unity and now every engine sort of
has its own model of how they make money
so uh you have something like a game
maker which has a yearly subscription
you have Pico 8 which are these tiny
little cute games where you just have a
one-time payment
um you have unreal where
um unreal games basically up until a
million dollars pay a million dollars in
Revenue they pay nothing and then
afterwards they pay five percent or they
can make a custom deal with unreal and
unity until a few days ago the business
model that we were aware of for Unity
was effectively there's three separate
layers that you can use and besides that
there is nothing you don't pay more you
pay those license fees and those could
be yearly or
free
um and then that was it and how do they
differentiate between like like what
allowed something to be free
so my favorite worst mistake in engine
marketing ever Mike is actually 100
correct one of the most one of one of
the best stories I think about unity in
real is that under the unreal license
if you uh use the free version you're
not actually supposed to put the made in
unreal logo
in front of your game no way but if you
take one of the commercial licenses you
have to put the logo in front of it that
is part of the deal
unity set if you use the free version
you have to put the logo in front of the
game but if you pay for it you can opt
out
so the result is that only really
professional commercial unreal games Wow
have the logo in front of it and
basically every hobbyist
Enthusiast like any person who's just
starting in unity has the unity logo in
front of it which is why most people
think that Unity makes bad games
I know real makes great games
I have never known what you just said
over the last 45 seconds and that blows
my mind what if that's why the podcast
exists Austin seriously
that was a really fascinating bit of
like two different marketing Notions
and just seeing what happens when they
when they play well that's got to mean
that Unity was trying to appeal to
Indies right that was their initial
angle for sure they were trying to be
they were making a very smart play and
it's it's reasonable like so you know
all of our games are unity um from day
one
um
yours Rami we did you ever ship you to
game lots of game maker stuff were you
ever immunity we did game maker we used
open Frameworks we used subject to see
and my most recent game Ridiculous
Fishing ex is actually a unity and that
game is coming out when the game is out
available right now on Apple arcade
please don't install that just please do
not just don't don't buy it it will cost
Robbie but the novio oh God but no the
the yeah that was but Unity definitely
for years made a really good play and
that's the the kind of heartbreaking
side of what's happened I know we still
haven't gotten to what's happened we'll
get there but like with with unity
usually has always been very
um very open and open to new developers
like they've been I only start using
Unity because they they ran out of great
London Meetup basically and I went there
as a way of meeting nerdy people in my
area and then eventually got into the
scene enough that I made Thomas Was
Alone like that's that was kind of my
entry point they're very very friendly
to people starting out which was a
really smart long-term play because then
you end up in a situation where you you
know create a career like they did for
me and now you know I've got you know 20
people working for me we've all got
licenses for Unity Pro we're all
building it out and they they make a
small amount of money from us as they
should do they historically have good
support like are they good about
supporting indie devs or or they were
again like scale has been a challenge I
think for the for Unity and I think you
should probably I think that's also a
reason behind what's going on right now
is is I think they were they were very
good at the start and then they just got
very very successful basically and I
think didn't necessarily scale that
support I read an article today that
said on Steam
um I don't know what the sample size
like it felt like this is nowhere near
enough of a total to be representative
of all of steam because I would think
there are many millions of games on
Steam but I don't but it said something
like whatever the sample was in the
article it was reading it said something
like 70 000 games were made in unity or
versus ten thousand and unreal yeah like
it's just that sounds like the right
ratio that sounds like you're right 80
percentage yes I I was floored at that
at that well because every
professionally built unity game on that
list as Remy said doesn't have the logo
at the start none of my games have a
Unity logo actually Thomas Was Alone
mine I can't remember Thomas I'm just
amazing that it's that yeah
it would really not be an exaggeration
to say that Unity is the most popular
game engine in the world in terms of
just like games coming out there's not
even unreal is not even close to
competition I mean if you factor in
Mobile then yeah by many also sir just
as an aside because I found it very
interesting apparently there aren't even
a hundred thousand games on Steam I also
would have thought there were millions
of games on Steam and apparently that's
because things get pulled so frequently
like people stop Studios making them
stop supporting them but the most recent
yeah statistic I can find which is them
corroborating by five separate sources
here is from 2021 saying 50 000 and 300.
that seems impossible because I've also
like over a thousand dollars a day or
whatever yeah exactly
because there's not enough team but on
Andrew on on uh IOS and Android probably
something around that range like there's
a lot of games being made also it's
exponential growth so there are a lot of
years when you're thinking about well
steam's been around for this long and
it's this day it's actually like that
you know it's sped up over time that's
how I measure it is I remember when
Banner Saga 1 came out which was in
summer of 2014 uh the guys at stoic told
me
um like it was like 33 games came out
this month on Steam and then by the time
Banner Saga 2 came out it was about
tenfold I think it was like 300 game and
then by the time Banner Saga 3 came out
it was like this month where you know a
thousand had come out so I just a really
funny way to measure it yeah
for two weeks there was nothing else
coming out and that's that's how that's
how those that generation of Indies uh
you know got where we are you know was
basically we were there any fish in the
sea that was that was it but off all the
games that that Austin is mentioning
that are coming out just the
overwhelming majority are our Unity just
to make clear just what the what the
skill of unity is and what the
importance of unity is so the pro
license and the the old plus license
which now doesn't exist anymore
basically developers pay per user per
seat as Mike said before and that's just
a fancy way of saying per user at the
studio
um so much that could get pretty high
yeah yeah each round a year
yeah wow which is actually to be clear
quite a low number like in terms of what
you think about the associated costs of
an employee two grand for the software
they use the that does all the stuff
right yeah Premiere Pros are super
expensive and like that but also just
think about the the scale of the
profitability of a game basically the
fact that it's an engine which is well
supported like there's to be clear none
of I think most developers or at least
most kind of at the professional level
kind of Developers wouldn't necessarily
have a problem with unity switching over
to a royalty-based system no that's not
what they did though that's not what
happened so you have unreal which has
were free until a million and then we
asked five percent of your revenue and
you had Unity with uh sorry one one
member I mean the crucial thing there is
only over the million so that's like a
tax bracket right so if you make if you
make a million and one dollars they want
five cents
yeah so the the first million they don't
charge five percent oh wow after that
million they charge five percent over no
way so
um that's how unreal has always done it
and now Unity always did it is it's free
and if you want access to the pro
licenses and you know the advantages
they're attached to it they pay proceed
and some of those advantages were you
know better support uh you can remove
the logo at the front like there was
enough value there at it per year
what's interesting is it when it when I
first got into Pro when I first started
using Pro it was well it was a one
thousand one-off payment I think right
so obviously things have changed since
then but yeah it still shows though
the ideas if you're uh if you're betting
on if you're betting on yourself and
you're presuming hey my game's gonna be
a giant hit Unity is that model is way
more profitable for you than a five
percent cut off of your you know 30
platform cut down if you make a hit if
you're making a hit and you're just like
rolling the dice I mean the the most
game developers pick their engine by
what they want to make right like I
think for most developers the business
model has never really been the biggest
consideration in choosing what tool you
use like if you can't afford it sure but
like
if you're making a game unreal is free
to start Unity is free to start game
maker costs 50 a year Pico is like
fifteen dollars total like The the cost
was never really what people are looking
at what people look at is okay does the
stool fit what we want to do you want to
do an unreal game that you're probably
doing something realistic or you're
looking for that sort of like scale
collaboration tools uh Unity mobile
Indie smaller teams usually people that
are working with more Juniors because
you get most Juniors trained with unity
right out of school right so because of
that great Outreach we talked about
earlier like Unity have played this very
well for a decade and have built a and
that's a big point of it as well is is
what you come in with skills on most
most people who make one game in unreal
make five games are unreal the most
people who make one game and use you
make five games in unity like if you're
once obviously as you're building up
those skills as a developer you tend to
stick to what you know
um unless you know circumstance makes
you switch over or the game you're
making drastically changes in something
where where the strengths or weaknesses
of one engine or the other come into but
I would say honestly over the last few
years there has been kind of a closing
of that gap on a lot of levels between
unreal and unity like in terms of what
to choose it's it's been a harder
decision I think for the last few years
I'd say unreal is now kind of pulling
forward with some of their technology
but for a long time they're like unreal
it's sanded off a lot of the edges that
made them unattractive to like a mobile
developer for example right I don't know
anything about engines for reference
Santa Monica Studios is proprietary
engine
um
the unreal is really good about like
upscaling like unreal is very good for
art
yeah unreal is is probably your your
graphics choice right if you're going
for like but also to be to be precise
they're good for specific types of art
styles like for a lot of
um 2D art for example I I wouldn't touch
on real like I wouldn't start real like
Unity has better 2D implementation than
on realized so really when it comes to
engines what teams are looking at is
what does our team know what have we
used what do we have like Legacy code in
our old code what is it in
um does
um does the engine fit what we need
usually you only see engine switches
when they're necessary because they're
expensive you retrain your team you have
to restart your knowledge base like you
have to learn how to collaborate in that
tool it's a lot of work it's a lot of
time
so
Unity decided that
um their current business model was kind
of unsustainable which I I frankly don't
think they're wrong right they're I
think that's probably true yeah it's
probably true right like they're they're
free for the overwhelming majority of
users
um and uh even if one of the users who
can pay they're also overwhelmingly free
because we're talking about you know if
you're making a team with the pro
version with 20 people for two years
that cost you 40 Grand sorry 80 grand 80
grand 20 yeah two years eighty yeah so
80 grand which which honestly if you're
making a game with that many people over
two years you are aiming to make
significantly more than 80 grand a
release so like so the number is
basically the number isn't really they
could be charging us more which I assume
is where this conversation started for
sure right so yeah
Unity was kind of unsustainable I think
that is not an unfair assessment and as
Mike said like really their their income
sources their their income streams were
fairly limited now they have their own
ad technology that you can Implement
that was apparently a large part of
their income over the last few years but
on the normal rank of file developer on
on the the the Indies the Double A's a
lot of the tripways they were just
making uh not a lot of money and of
course Apple have jumped down the ads
the ads route as well so that that's
kind of blocked that Revenue stream it's
quite additional person I didn't know
that yeah so Unity came up with an idea
they needed to make more money
and they basically have a number of very
common options like the revenue share
that unreal uses uni decided to innovate
earlier money making notion of buying
WETA uh I don't think has uh doesn't pad
out so well I don't think I'm a lot of
like uh mailbox money apparently yeah
no and there were some other this I
don't know how much advice NDA but there
were some other approaches they took to
try and increase revenue streams as well
this definitely wasn't their first idea
but it's definitely their worst idea
they came up with something new
um something that has never been tried
in the games industry uh because it is
just by all means by every perspective a
terrible idea I think my my guess of
what happened is they looked at games
like ancient impact like some of the
biggest games made in unity some of the
most popular games in unity went how can
we make money
off of this and they came up with the
idea of instead of saying we're going to
make money by Revenue they said we're
going to make money for install
and
that at first glance that might sound
like it makes sense right somebody
downloads the game they install it and
then unity's deal is if you made over
two hundred thousand dollars and have
more than two hundred thousand downloads
or installs to be precise installs
um you start getting charged 20 cents
per install
so you would say Okay per user that's 20
cents but when Unity says install they
do mean install which means that if a
user installs uninstalls and installs
again
that would technically trigger another
20 cents or if a user upgrades their
computer
and installs the game again that's 20
cents if they install it on two
computers that's 20 cents and
that okay that's 40 cents that's not
that bad right
um but take for example free to play
game yeah free to play game have
millions of downloads right to to be at
a point where you have two hundred
thousand dollars in revenue on a
free-to-play game you're looking at five
million plus installs right
that's one million dollar
in costs you know it's just so baffling
because it's oh we're only a layer one
or something
I found myself going it's it's like a
fine because there's no like you said
free to play is the ultimate
demonstration of this there's no Revenue
to the developer associated with an
install unto itself so I just the notion
of monetizing that feels like a
punishment or something it doesn't
really feel like you don't want people
to install your game I just kept
assuming I was missing please
buy the game do not install
just don't play it I saw someone make
the joke that Steve uses or like way
ahead of the curve on this one we've
been buying it forever
keep that up but what happens what is
there is there any kind of um business
more model or very popular way of
funding indie games that would in any
way conflict with this oh yeah sometimes
yeah something where they pay once and
then in exchange the game might be free
let's let's say it was so successful it
was how a majority of indie games are
probably funded right
something like uh
yeah yeah so Game Pass basically is
completely wrecked by this right yes
yeah the effective way a Game Pass deal
works is the developer gets a lump sum
of money
and then an exchange the game is
available like as a download for free
for subscribers of Game Pass for a
specific period of time millions of
people yeah so Game Pass yeah it's now
terrifying but you know when you when
you sort of like
think through this what makes people
reinstall games well or what makes
people install games multiple times Well
demos that you can unlock or demos that
you can expand make people install games
multiple times updates make people
reinstall games right
um uh that actually updates is a fairly
big one like you know it's now a risk to
update it's now a risk you're
incentivized not to
yeah because people might reinstall your
game
or just like I bought a steam deck uh
and oh no I played Cult of the Lamb like
back and forth between my PC and my
studio Cult of the Lamb who've given
who've done an announcement saying
they're pulling the game they're not
obviously but they're doing the joke I
love that yeah they said bye call to the
lamb now because we're deleting it on
January 1st which I actually kind of
wouldn't be surprised if they did so
which is when this comes into effect
Australia but we're only on the first
level sorry right okay so so that is
problem one problem two actually is
something a lot of just kind of uh
pointed at which is okay they pulled the
game January 1st right that should stop
it right but it doesn't because under
these terms it's the installs account so
even if we stop selling the game or we
pull the game entirely
people can still install the game
we are not able to remove our games
and then I take it off the platform
um that you can still download it from
Steam because you should be able to you
paid for it it's reasonable it's good
consumer focused decision right but it
does mean I'm screwed also DRM free
builds now absolutely unacceptable for
any unity game so if you like DRM free
games you like updates you like uh games
as a service you like games that update
frequently
all of those business model are under
severe pressure why does it looks like
yeah the most DRM free of all piracy
drm3 is dangerous because it means that
anybody can download the game and
install it on as many devices as they
want security was to be able to track
that
so Unity says
um or layer three uh but that might be
layer three you're right basically
um one of the things that that really
happens here is developers don't
traditionally track installs
for a variety of reasons some of them
that
we what's the most important reason we
don't track them though it's technically
impossible to [__] track them that's
the main reason we don't there's not
really a way to do it that doesn't
violate a whole bunch of loss right
right and that's Layer Two is is it is
impossible to track installs of a game
without
lying or breaking the law right to our
understanding of the technology in the
current memory it is possible and I of
course in a good faith way assume that
Unity have invented a new technology
that allows for this right
technical in the last 24 hours from my
from my professional experience it is
currently impossible to track how many
times I don't know how many times any of
my games have been installed rammy
doesn't know either
you can think yeah so there's so
I mean you would need I was just gonna
say I mean I imagine it would be one of
those that if there was some way to do
it that wasn't you know like creepy
spyware style uh uh privacy violations I
imagine it is actually very useful
information to developer as if there
wasn't just some horrible way to achieve
it oh if we could I would think it would
be don't get me wrong we love game
developers love metrics if we could do
it without being creepy we would have
done by now it would also it's worth
saying it would also be the ultimate
anti-piracy tool if you could track
installs you would be able to block any
install done they don't like missions so
we would have removed piracy from the
industry many years ago this technology
actually existed right I see it um so so
to expand on that say we don't have a
good way of tracking installs right or
we could track the number of installs or
we could estimate the number of installs
we could get fairly close right we can
probably do that
um we can call home every time somebody
installs a game or try to call home
everybody installs the game
um breaking international data
protection laws you know that that's
fine we're the tech industry those rules
so DRM DRM becomes an issue like not
having DRM effectively means that
anybody can install the game as
oftentimes as they want and we don't
actually have any Rights Management
because that's really what DRM means we
don't have the ability to withhold an
installation from somebody right the way
DRM works now is that you can install
the game but then not run it that's a
financial liability now because if
somebody really doesn't like me for
something I said on you know some social
media you're very non-confrontational
never taking against you you've never
been controversial
no absolutely not
um say somebody doesn't like me what
they can do is they can spin up a
thousand virtual machines
and just installing all of them yeah and
that's that's the scariest part is and
and who and who are the people making
Unity games or who are a subset of
people making Unity games people from
protected groups people who are feel
uncomfortable on the internet people who
are being attacked it could be the new
release
you could you could literally put rammy
into a half a million dollars of debt
please do not download Ridiculous
Fishing ex and install it just do not
download any of them just buy them
download mine as long as they were
published by someone else
so we we get into a lot of weird
problems right the the first real like
layer as a micropherson is the legal one
the the the way of tracking these games
is non-precise we don't have any way of
saying like this number is correct and
developers have no way to verify the
amount that Unity gives them we don't
know Unity says they have a proprietary
model that they can't describe so which
they said in public that they have a
model and they won't tell us what it is
a tweet that's been deleted I mean yeah
yeah technically they're they're a
proprietary model their model for
telling us how many installs there are
is trust me bro like that that's the
that's the model as you Fork over money
small Indie Dev with low Revenue right
exactly why are they saying because I
remember seeing them say
90 of people who use Unity won't be
affected by any of it that's because of
the 200 000. yeah that also means that
ten percent their their defenses don't
worry ninety percent of you are not
going to be financially successful
enough first of all your games aren't
good enough don't worry about it but
like they said 90 and I'm guessing they
may that could also be nonsense right 90
means ten percent right now we just
described that Unity is the most popular
game making tool on Earth ten percent of
those people are now at Financial Risk
because of how this works and literally
we have no we have no valves we have no
way of shutting this down we can't stop
this We Can't Stop installs we can't
block installs
so there comes part two of the of the
legal part before you move on to part
two is the uh is the other aspect just
to point out there because I think I
know we we talked to a broad audience
here who often aren't game developers
200 000 on an individual by individual
based obviously a lot of money 200 000
as the gross income from a video game is
very low because if you think about like
you know how many people work at a games
company how how long they work on a game
for 200 000 is not an impressively big
number
um so most Indies any Indie that you or
someone listening to this have have
heard of or have played their game
chances are they are very close to or
well over that line
um it's just worth pointing out because
I think 200 000 is one of those numbers
that sounds very big when we think of it
in an individual context but for a games
company that is not it's one of the
weird hard thresholds across it's one of
the weirdest things that you have to
learn when you become a you know you
found a Studios you have to put the one
hat on and go to the supermarket and go
like wow three dollars for Coca-Cola I'm
not spending three dollars of this
lettuce yeah right and then you put on
the other hat and you're like well 300
000 not sure if we can do that you know
like it's it's really yeah it stops
being your money I think yeah right
we've been through a similar Journey on
that haven't we it's definitely like a
yeah it's a completely different thing
right yeah so Mike is right 200k on a
game is not a lot and that is usually
200k this is revenue right so this is
before costs before taxes before any of
that so paid your team before any of
that it's yes before the platform gets
there thirty percent
by not saying which platform we're
talking about so your Revenue can be 200
000 but for a lot of Independence free
it's pre-platform costs also it's
Revenue yeah well but I think I think of
the developers I guess you're talking
like like like true gross revenue right
uh in my mind it was the revenue coming
into the studio which would be after the
platform cost but the purposes of any
business conversation always assume the
other guy the bit the the number that
best serves the other guy is usually the
one you want to assume but that really
is nuts because now you're charging
where a huge per I mean that 30 is not a
small amount of the money that a thing
could be making that that you know Steam
and will whatever else are taking so
like that's that makes it but even worse
even if you don't count that taxes
salaries Hardware Investments all of
that like the you know out of the game
development as soon as the game hits
200k your Unity subscription you which
you're still paying in this scenario
right well we'll stop that uh that's not
stopping no wow so um so that's that
part right then there's actually two
other legal parts to this which the
first one is this is a change that
actually let's start with the other one
the installs right
Unity originally said that every install
and reinstall would count
after the initial backlash it is they
actually said okay it's only the initial
install that counts
so some and the reason they said they
could not track what it was an install
or reinstall is because there is no way
of tracking that the next day they
backtracked on that and said they do
have a wave track and the problem is for
that to work eight install tracking
already isn't entirely accurate but for
that to work they need to be able to tie
the install to a person
I don't have that technology would be my
assumption based on the current
situation unless if they're tying it to
any identifying information including an
IP address that is a violation of
European law
because which we're definitely not
accusing them off around me right we're
definitely where we are talking
hypothetically yeah
we're speculating 100 100
I'm in the Netherlands I can say this
but y'all might not
so they've been pretty specific
yesterday they tweeted
how we Define and count installs is
assuming the install and revenue
thresholds are met we will only count
net new installs on any device that
starts January 1st so you guys are fine
until then then you aren't reinstall
charges we are not going to charge a
FIFA reinstalls which means that they
can tell if something has been
reinstalled like that is a lot of data
um fraudulent installs charges we're not
going to charge a fee for fraudulent
installs we'll work directly with you on
cases where again I mean this is
something they need to know what a
fraudulent install of a DRM free games
I'm gonna read this list and just for
every single thing that Alana is going
to read just think how would they know
right yeah it's also I suspect all of
this stuff is just response to the the
feedback then they didn't plan to do any
of this originally so trials partial
play demos and automation installs
develop charges we are not going to
count these towards your install count
how well they know
Early Access games are not considered
demos web and streaming games that makes
sense uh charity related insoles the
pricing change and install account will
not be applied to your charity bundles
that the charity one is particularly
it's my favorite flying charity for me
because what I if you're gonna charge me
20 cents for every install that isn't
sharing I'm starting at Mike Bethel I'm
really excited save the children are
getting 19 cents from every game I ship
from now on right because then there's
charity games every game is going to
become a charity game
it just becomes the most charitably
given year in human history because it
was just like funneling of
Unity actually like played the bad guy
to be like God here save the world
The Joker to all of our Batman yeah it
works
the charity one happened because
somebody did the calculus on what
happens when a really well-meaning Indie
developer that has two hundred thousand
dollars in Revenue would add their game
to one of those big charity bundles that
happened over the last few years and one
of them the bundle against racial
inequality and Injustice
um took place a few years ago that had
eight hundred thousand downloads
so if you are in any Indie developer
just that just hit their 200 000 Revenue
right we just hit that that will give
you 600 000 qualifying downloads
one-fifth is that is almost 150k
if that happened after you pay your
taxes
you're not bad you're out of business
you're you're in depth you're in depth
to Unity yeah because you tried to help
a charity so now genuinely if this isn't
resolved anyone who's got a game in Game
Pass right now will have to get it
removed before January because oh yeah
that's alone a number of Studios yeah
and not just that free-to-play Studios
we'll have to find a way to deal with
this I actually talked to one
free-to-play Studio before that
calculator that
um their margin basically their their
um per install Revenue right because how
free to play companies do it this day
calculate their full revenue and then
divide that per user to see what their
per user revenue is is 18 cents
dead so at a 20 cent cost
that's per user not for install right a
user can install multiple times this
company will go out of business yeah I
was reading an artist this
um yeah this article from gamediscover
dot co
uh in his new in his newsletter he was
like it's not normally what I talk about
but this does sort of relate and there's
a quote in here from a developer that
had posted something on Reddit where
they said our studio focuses on mobile
games for kids we don't display
advertising to kids because we are
against it and we don't [__] want to
and the only way to monetize those games
is through in-app purchases which uh we
should be in charge of
uh we should be in charge to decide how
and how much to monetize those users not
Unity but so but but according to our
last year figures if 2024 were to be the
same as 2023 was
um or 22 I assume Unity would uh would
be owed 109 of the revenue of our
company wow
because of this and I think it was
specifically because of the mobile terms
of in-app purchases and the specifics
around the language of how those various
things are being counted towards these
numbers and and whatnot like the
different business models
it hurts every level it hits every level
from free to play to Indy the one group
that makes Unity games that will not be
negatively impacted by this is the
gambling companies who are exempt who
are exempt they don't have to pay 20
cents if you're if you make that's the
other out
um why yeah saliva's way ahead of the
game on this
why but like are they exempt the
gambling I guess wow I actually haven't
quite figured out why it's exam but it's
probably because with the gambling world
they're making deals with really large
corporations yep and larger companies
and they probably have their contracts
like the hammered down in ways that we
don't there are just so many yeah and
one person that I keep wondering sorry
is um the fraudulent one gets me because
surely people will try to do that right
oh is there customer service doesn't
respond immediately I imagine you still
have to pay all those fees and then what
you just wait around for a refund even
though you're getting the opportunity
contest will be given an opportunity to
contest for a few months Alana if we
want to be paid yeah yeah
but what if you're what if I'm a
developer and I and I am after January
1st on the hook for all this and I just
decide [__] that I just won't like what
is their enforcement mechanism do they
have some way to sabotage my I get they
could sue me or whatnot but no no no
they don't have to sabotage you they
just sue you yeah I see so I but that
does that mean that they're currently
preparing for what would be presumably
thousands of lawsuits I mean I mean if
assuming again taking a good faith
assumption that they've invented a form
of install tracking that doesn't break
any international data collection laws
they I mean they theoretically would be
able to shut down all our games if they
have that level of access to our games
and the data generated from our games
then they could theoretically shut down
our games they can also stop access of
course to us using the engine our
subscriptions all that stuff so we you
could you could kind of hurt us that way
I yeah it's it's a lot and and and where
it gets even more funny is um I know one
of the criticisms that was raised was
like The Game Pass thing their answer to
that is um they're going to charge
Microsoft I'm really excited to hear uh
Phil's announcements
Microsoft is sort of a positive because
like at least if they go up against
Microsoft and they ruin Game Pass which
is obviously such an important model for
Microsoft they're going to have trouble
there like that is not going to be a
good Corporation to Corporation
conversation well at least
exceptional amounts of money to be a fly
on the wall for that comment they've
already had some I think
but the funny thing is like I don't know
how Unity intends to charge Microsoft
for a license I signed with unity true
like well even better how are they gonna
how you didn't sign this license you
signed an earlier so that's the other
legal challenge
yeah yeah so this is one of those
scariest things about this right the
unity license has a clause in it that
basically has a 12-month commitment
period right if you use Unity you commit
to agreeing to the terms of service for
12 months right
um and that has to do with when Revenue
comes in and like their ability to to
you know get paid for things
um and for you not to screw them over
basically
um the 12-month commitment period like
in other words you if you release a game
and it makes a shitload of money on week
one and then you pull it off the store
you wouldn't be able to get out of them
because they're like you know you
wouldn't be able to say I I canceled the
terms right that's what the point of
that is I assume yeah
um
this change was announced in early
September 2023 it goes into effect on
January 1st 2024 which actually leaves
you no time to to disagree with this you
cannot pull out you cannot cancel you
cannot stop using Unity services in time
for this not to happen now the second
part of that that is messed up is that
the way these terms are worded it
doesn't just apply to games that you are
bringing out after January 1st
it applies to any game you've ever
launched that uses Unity so if I decided
to use Unity back in 2009
for a thing that game I now need to
install track or figure out a way to
make sure that this hasn't gone viral
behind my back
and it's you know like
making money all of a sudden because if
it hits two hundred thousand dollars
this starts applying and at that point
there is actually a way to upgrade so
that those numbers go higher if you go
to the pro license then the numbers go
up from 200 000 to a million but you
know effectively the same thing
continues to apply at some point if the
game gets more downloads then you're
generating in Revenue
you're going to be losing money that's
where it gets really interesting given
how many studios have been bought in the
intervening time of since making a unity
game so you now have a lot even though
ramy's absolutely right you can see
largely used by smaller developers right
mobile developers a lot of those
companies did very well with their Unity
games and then got bought up by the
likes of EA Microsoft Nintendo in the
few like those kind of companies so now
those companies are the ones who are
tied to specific Legacy games and yeah
he's gonna be hitting them up um
because like you're gonna go to
Microsoft and get money from a game we
released in 2011 good luck well done
give it a go yeah I also really feel
like this isn't legal and that's because
didn't Amazon just get like find like
500 million just for checking cookies
like there's no way that this passes
we have to assume Alana that they've
invented a new technology that makes it
legal right impossible in good faith and
also figure out whether an install is
fraudulent
you can tell if it's charitable bye
always
yeah no it's it's amazing it can it's an
algorithm that can detect uh the ethical
status
think of the amount of time that's gonna
be saved I mean piracy gets sold January
1st
um I can't wait again goodbye Unity is
the correct take here yeah that is our
assumption we have to work under that
stuff why wouldn't it because otherwise
I'd be breaking UK long
um so the the the general the general
sort of like the the four major points
right is that Unity is now
technically the only engine where the
business model can sync your studio
because you're successful like that's
the fullest point for the slide there is
no engine only engine yeah there's no
engine that can bankrupt you because
you're doing well right Unity now
technically can and it's not technical I
have over 50 developers in my DMs that
are looking to jump ship and a number of
them has just run the numbers
and go until like yeah that's 108 it
doesn't take longer to right like it
really this is not like fear-mongering
and the first response from Unity was
very much like you're clearly confused
by this no you're talking to a bunch of
maths nerds
we did it twice we are not confused what
you have said is your policy puts most
of us at Financial Risk there's a very
simple in the developers who wouldn't be
two swap engines is that
so the problem is yes you can but it
won't help you because it's about
installs on games you've already made in
the past it doesn't matter whether you
change now you can damage control future
projects but you can't stop this you
there's already an interesting
discussion happening
um some preeminent kind of uh sheridans
which is one of the largest uh
game-centric law firms in the UK I know
is putting some stuff together and
looking at it like there's going to be
some challenges to this again I'm just
commenting on those challenges and not
to decide in those challenges
yeah man UK is rough with this
um you like UK it's scary how right how
careful you have to be with your
language but no it's um yeah so that so
this will be challenged I do not believe
that this happens in January I just I
can't believe it's it's astonishing how
undebaked this was and as an
announcement it is incredibly obvious
that the many many very smart engineers
and lawyers who work at Unity did not
okay this right this would not have made
it past there's a lot of resignations
happening
even if they take this back the trust is
gone because right even if they take it
back now all the people who currently
work with unity should be concerned that
they will try and pull something like
this again like this is so terrifying
for so many studios that I can't imagine
a lot of people will want to work with
unity again
no all that their messaging is you're
confused
I mean I think it's a solid first play I
know your way Come Back
by the time this comes about this they
may have gone through three more of
those uh posts by the time this comes
out normally when I when I am making the
worst business decision in the history
of video games I I would also decide to
Gaslight the entire industry like while
they're watching that's just a gen just
a great idea but it's I I don't know
like so so the four things that I sort
of got stuck on is like a it's
retroactive and that's terrifying to me
because if they can say now okay
actually you owe us 20 on the thing you
made years ago well their old TOS
actually said that you can stick to the
TOs you release the game under right as
long as you stay on the the as long as
you stay near the version of unity that
you used to develop a game including for
bug fix and stuff like that yeah that
dos would apply they quietly removed
that clause
about a year ago I think
um so that cost just disappeared the the
whole TOS disappeared yesterday right
yeah well really so yeah happening
um the second thing is they're not
allowing anybody to to build right you
can't say okay before this goes in we
stop working with unity Services we
revoke access to we stop using those
Services we stop using their products
um and we we stop you can't do that
because it happens too soon and it
applies to games that you've already
launched under a different license
number three Unity should not be able to
charge for something that we don't make
any money on and can't control it's that
combination right because you can charge
us for things that don't make money
that's reasonable like that happens
right like sometimes it's just okay I'm
gonna pay for a Photoshop subscription
I don't anymore but say I did
um
and I don't use it I still get charged
yeah that's that's a common business
you're paying rent you're paying a
service then yeah but
we do not have control over this and the
only way for us to get a number is
through their proprietary block Black
Box model that works by the trust me bro
method and then the final thing is
really
they
they really just shouldn't they
shouldn't use a a thing that doesn't
have a limit yeah like installs are
unlimited uncontrollable there's no way
for us to control them reach them and
revoke them stop them block them we
cannot do anything
when it comes to install so if this
starts threatening us
we have no recourse there is nowhere to
go for us besides just watch ourselves
go to bankruptcy because our game got
popular right at the end of the year
where the game made 200k in January
right yeah
you would want to not be in those top 10
you would not want your game to be
successful which is a wild thing for an
engine to do that's the thing that's the
thing that I don't get and I I
definitely all joking about what I
shouldn't shouldn't say aside like I do
genuinely I and me and Romney have had
many conversations over a decade in this
vein but like I always try and assume
that the other person uh the the other
side of the business thing
um is probably acting from a position of
self-interest trying to motivate me to
work in a certain way oh that Clause is
in the contract because they're worried
I'll do this yeah want me to do that or
whatever that's why
it doesn't incentivize or explain itself
in a way where you go oh they want us
all to make free to play games you know
what I mean like that would make more
sense that I could pass I would
understand oh okay they're incentivizing
that it's it's they're they're trying to
push us towards a genre that they
believe is going to make them more money
there's no Rhyme or Reason to this which
is genuinely why it feels stupid I'm
generally not in favor of assuming
that a corporation who's been around and
successful for a long time
are stupid like the a board of people
had to work on this that's what makes it
more confusing there's going to be an
amazing about this a few years I would
want to read the I want to find out what
happened how's the policy on this
podcast of like hearsay things from the
Grapevine oh we talk about a lot I mean
we talk about a lot of [__]
I mean you you can say whatever you like
and I will not because I can do nothing
that rhymes we've definitely said a lot
of incorrect stuff on this as a British
is and I do not know of the truth to any
of the validity of anything around me is
about to say and I do not support us so
basically the the Grapevine on this is
that there has been the idea of finding
a way to charge some sort of percentual
or like recurring fee for Unity has been
in the banking for over a year it's not
a new idea which I think is fair enough
right as you were saying fair enough
they needed to change them if they'd
announce the unreal royalty there would
have been about two hours of Twitter
discourse and then it would all just
move people would have just gone like
darn yeah God damn it but also fair
enough come on yeah and then if you
really really wanted to go like it's
less than unreal they could have gone
four percent and then that would have
been nice yeah that would have been the
nice the nice PR for them no one there
would have there would have been a mini
backlash because the mini backlash did
anything major and there's definitely a
segment of game developers who that
would cause right more expensive but it
would genuinely harm the mees and
rammies more than it would harm anybody
else the hobbyists you know it's it's
the people who have made who have had
financial success and that would that a
royalty punishes or takes a reasonable
amount of money from right and and on
top of that they actually
um another thing that is really baffling
to me is they actually expanded your
your rights under the free license so
you you know it used to be at 100K you
had to move 100K Revenue you had to move
to the Pro or plus license
that's gone like they they oh did that
go yeah they stopped I think that went
up to to uh 200k or just it didn't it
it's not there at all anymore so they
actually expanded their free tier which
is lovely and if they had just gone with
a revenue share I think most people
actually would have been positive about
this change because as a hobbyist it
means you don't have that that thing at
the top anymore and after it goes there
you just start paying four percent
people people if you're obvious the idea
of making a million dollars what do I
care a million dollars you can take you
can take five cents on every dollar
that's fine and and the people who have
the most established companies are also
like yeah that's reasonable that's fair
and it scales to your success which is
the point ramy's making where there is a
ceiling to that number there is there is
it is very trackable it's very
understandable there are metrics I can't
tell you how many people have installed
Thomas Was Alone I can tell you to a
single person how many people have
bought Thomas Was Alone yeah of course I
need to know that for bookkeeping
accounting taxes all this stuff often
people have installed Thomas Was Alone
I've installed it like 45 times because
you just keep releasing the things
I've played it so often I I have
in-depth it's only place I have given
Mike in-depth in-depth feedback on why I
think the title was wrong so useful yeah
yeah I've said you redirect
like I've said on the show before that
every every that like five or six of my
games are specifically named to troll
around me but because he's criticism of
Thomas Was Alone was that it should have
been called rectangles or something no
no it was just because we're alone
listen Tom Thomas is not alone in that
game Thomas was not alone in the game I
think I I'm calling narrative that's how
storytelling works you also you also
said it should have been about you
should have been you should have used
the word rectangle square because that's
why then every game of mine is called a
shape word so volume birth
that makes me the most angry like volume
is a game about being quiet why is
volume again about being quiet like it's
the problem is now I work with Disney I
have to use good names
adjectively noun
yeah that's that's the go-to that's a
good mobile yeah anyway for any mobile
game that has that please don't install
it because it's likely made in unity
um just buy it the the main thing is
this is not a walk you can't walk this
one back no I don't think so either
trust me yeah it shows uh it shows the
lack of judgment which is genuinely
right the Grapevine real quick so I
understand that this has been in the
world for over a year
but that per install
was brought up shot down internally to
the point where everybody assumed it was
not gonna happen
and then announced
and that there was nothing in between
that that as far as I can tell the
people I've talked to that work in unity
or work with people that work at Unity
the the original response was just a
combination of utter confusion and anger
there's not an engineer at unity and
there's a lot of Engineers at UNC there
is not a single engineer Unity who no
amazing world-class Engineers there's
not a single one of them who thought
that you could with current technology
uh track installs them again right not a
single one right and and further to
distinguish between different types of
installs right yeah like the just that
that is a three minute that's the kind
of conversation and you know I'm I'm
boss of the studio I walk into a room
with my programmers every day and say
something really really stupid and they
say no Mike that's not possible and I go
oh that's a shame okay fair play and I
move on that's what you're meant to do
you're meant to be the boss who goes in
and asks the professionals what can and
can't be done my guess is that
who walked in here
is maybe some you know very corporate
person who was only thinking about
mobile
right the thing they were focused on
exclusively but it still kills the
mobile developers oh for sure oh hello
yeah
I would understand this to be clear like
I would understand if this was something
that only negatively impacted Indies but
really worked with the mobile people I
would understand I'd be offended by it
but I'd understand it yeah because you
know we're we're disposable we don't
make anyone that much money we're kind
of the cool interesting thing on the
side but Mobile's where it's at if this
was something that massively served the
mobile developers and screwed us over I
would at least understand the reasoning
but yeah but this Trader bankrupts
mobile developers especially free to
play once and it also really screws over
Indies because we like we like giveaways
we like free updates
we like charity bundles we we like
putting our games in bundles where you
can pay what you want like all of these
things
all right now we've all got to the
positions we are by being generous in
that way right knowing when to out and a
bit of self-interest when to use those
opportunities to talk about our games
yeah it's just such a net negative for
like
the community and it's probably why I
really wanted to talk about this is I'm
seeing game devs blow up about it but
I'm not really seeing Gamers talk about
it and I don't know that they're
currently aware of the negatives that
apply to Gamers as well uh which are
also tremendous um just the amount of
Studios we've had to post things like
Mega crit posted
uh regarding slay the Spire that they've
been working on again for the past two
years it's in unity and it's the first
time they've ever had to say that they
are going to change engines unless the
changes are completely reverted
um it's it's so nuts and we'll probably
delay a bunch of games like just
and that's one area which I am worried
about because I think the audience still
thinks that you can take again you're
making in unity and Port it into unreal
we see that we see a tweet about that go
virally every week just Chuck it into
unreal this takes two months to put a
game into unreal that is not the case
and I think players are gonna be aware
of that when people have to make
difficult decisions about this stuff and
it's it's strange because you know
people think of of engines as these
these sort of magical programs that sort
of glue your your game together but
really what it is it's sort of like a
Lego box
right it's these building blocks and you
can use or not use certain building
blocks but the building blocks you have
shape what you build on top of it so
some engines are structured in specific
ways other engines are structured in
other ways but it's really hard to take
the thesis that are yours from a Lego
thing and then put them on a structure
that is not built for that at all it's
like putting Lego you're moving the
intellectual property that's what you're
doing you you've made a you've made a
house in Lego and you now have a design
for a house and now you're going to make
it the little circles are a different
size
right well you just have to go and
reinterpret everything you did and it's
it's yeah it's gonna have everything
there's going to be delays there's going
to be a lot of canceled games so it's
going to be a blood bar just the
emphasize how big that statement is that
they're considering switching to another
engine what Mike said at the start is
really true an engine as a framework is
something that developers get good at
you get good at Unity right yes
absolutely being good at unity means
that if you start on unreal
you're you're gonna have an advantage to
somebody who has never used either right
like being being a better game developer
it doesn't matter what tool is going to
make you a better game developer in
general but to learn where what the
quickest way is of doing something what
the most performant way is of doing
something what the safest way of doing
something is how you can best
collaborate in a tool how you can best
uh export things on a tool the methods
of getting it on specific system the
specific quirks and bugs and weirdnesses
which way is up is genuinely a
difference between engines right like we
did forward up left right points in a
different direction yeah they just point
in different directions like everything
changes and just I think people don't
get that necessarily like the game
development is done in the margins like
it's very like like you know there's a
there's a lot of videos and I always
moan about these these videos where it's
like I made Oblivion in a week that kind
of YouTube video if someone throwing
some assets together and unreal to make
a video game and have it run like a
solid frame rate it's not just that tiny
two second slice
that that's there are people I have
someone I have several someone's but I'm
thinking of a particular person
he he has he has put
a decade of his life into knowing
exactly how to get great performance
from Unity yeah like he is the best and
when we put we put a build or to him and
it comes back running beautifully on you
know a lesser console that's amazing and
that's something that makes uh that he's
made a career around these and he's
obviously very valuable because of that
and all of that knowledge if I decide
we're going to Unreal with our next game
he has to basically start from scratch
we are not talking about how to you know
loading up a tutorial and learning how
to place a cube in unreal that's very
learnable and trainable but we are
talking about people who have dedicated
their careers you are essentially
devaluing people's skills and thus kind
of hurting video games as a whole like
it's it feels like a strong word to use
but as a result all these people who
have these skills working in unity are
going to be worse at what they do again
I don't like the the word worse but you
know what I mean if they have to do it
all on a new engine thus making video
games as a whole a bit worse for a while
right and I've seen the snide response
from people of like well you shouldn't
you shouldn't entrust everything to an
engine you should be and it's like well
we have to entrust everything to an
engine
I made a bet that panned out quite well
for 12 years yeah um
like it's it's yeah it's it's it's a
tricky one and and the sort of the the
the Ripple effects of this are also huge
because of a studio like a mega crit or
anything like them would have to make
that choice would have to make that
change that affects their future output
right their future output won't be as
fast updates to old games will not
happen because they're switching engines
like they're gonna have to eventually
let go of unity Talent OR retrain Unity
Talent right those are really the only
two options you have
um updates cost money now
which is also bad right if anybody
reinstalls your game because you release
an update that's bad so that's dangerous
they're probably closing their license
but you don't need to avoid that so they
can't even update the game if they
wanted to so there's just like there's
gonna be this this this inflection point
if this continues on January 1st where a
whole lot of developers are going to
choose not to work with unity anymore at
the first possible moment they can get
that and it hurts everybody just across
the board everybody in theory even Unity
because every foot will leave I mean
it's been a great idea has a Compound
Effect like because if Unity if you if
Unity have shot themselves in the foot
to the extent where this is actually
going to damage their business which I
don't know if they have I think anyone
does yet if
Mike doesn't know rammy knows I don't
know but if that's the case then there's
a real concern there of like well what
about like future support what about
support for upcoming platforms what
about this what about that like there's
those of us who are working on
multi-year projects have to be thinking
on a on a different Horizon and there's
concerns there which are obviously
behind three or four different ndos but
like there's there's lots of concerns
coming up there as well and that's gonna
have a big impact that's one of those
ones that we'll be seeing the outcomes
of this week for quite some time yeah
it's um they've got to walk it back
they've walked back some things it's now
saying like they have a tweet that says
it's not retroactive
like some of it is
they've been trying to claim that but
what they mean with not retroactivists
they're claiming that they're changing
they're not judging for 10 years no the
the the basically the
I think they're trying to get on out on
a legal like specificity which is
effectively saying we're not actually
retroactively of buying anything we're
starting the terms on January 2024. I
see you think they're being fancy that's
what they did the previous time they uh
they discussed that but let me read what
they have here because the other thing
is they just keep changing what they're
saying like like and that's what makes
it feel underprepared again I imagine
this will continue to happen
yeah but like for example it has to be a
full walk back and I'm not even sure if
that's enough my favorite one here is we
don't count fraudulent installs or
install bombing either a great insult
bombing was not a phrase until four days
ago just for the record it didn't oh my
God yeah um but now it's a word that's
when you know you've messed up is when
there's a new negative term for an
assumption about a a bullying behavior
that doesn't yet exist right yeah so we
won't count from an insults or install
bombing either as part of our model we
are creating solutions to address the
problem of double clowning
reinstallations
like they're about to install something
of which they do not have a technical
implementation a technical
implementation that every person that
works in development can tell you is not
possible Right
so while it's yeah there's an interest
yeah just top to bottom it's very
confusing though I do also want to note
apparently this happened today when you
look at Unity news they got a credible
death threat that forced two officers to
close
that's most don't do that no but we
don't support that
that's not what we're talking about here
that's that's [__] pathetic yeah no
no and you know that that's kind of the
other part like like Mike said there's a
lot of amazing people at Unity this is a
company that was built on helping
developers uh students people just
starting kids
um make their first and we often then
hire those people in so you've got all
that that Community I think most of the
people I went to that London drinks with
10 years ago now work at Unity like
that's the it's the 90s 99 of the people
at Unity do not deserve any disrespect
or frustration there is too much of that
right like this is one of the things
that I I keep yelling out on on on X
um
yeah
you know this is something that that is
important like you know and especially
also as as Gamers sort of start to
realize what the effects of this is
going to be on on you know the the hobby
the medium the the games the developers
that they love
um if this continues it's not the right
way to stop this by like yelling at
people by death threats by any of that
like just in in general what we need to
do is just make clear that this is bad
for games it's bad for game development
it's bad for the people that make the
game she loves yeah right it's it's bad
for the players it's bad for everybody
there's literally nobody that wins here
and with the way they're spanning out
even Unity is not winning like literally
nobody is winning here like this is this
is just utter and complete disruption
and chaos and for me the the saddest
thing is just like I really like Unity
yeah I really really like Unity I think
unity's mission in the games industry
unity's achievements in the games
industry as Mike is saying a lot of the
people that started out in unity as kids
now our professional game developers
they're working in the engine they're
working on their games they're running
game studios they're they're like people
that took the leap into independent game
development it was my generation Super 8
camera like it just it opened the door
and and that's the set that's what's
tragic about this and a lot of good
people work I love a lot of people are
currently resigning from Unity
um but um do you guys see that the CEO
pulled stocks out like quite recently
before this was announced not many
though right I saw that going around it
wasn't 500 it was 2 000. yeah no it
wasn't like compared to what he has
that's more ridiculous it was like uh
yeah I think that's been over I think
that's been overplayed I suspected so
too much fifth or something 125th of
this yeah it's not nothing but like I
don't know that's not my community he's
continuously been pulling out he's been
he's been he's been pulling out of unity
for a long time which I never think is a
good sign when your cea is a great size
CEO keeps selling stock in the company
that they run yeah probably especially
when your company has invented a new
technology that can track the
installation
I swear to God if they had ins if they
had developed that Unity would stop
existing tomorrow because they would
pivot to selling that technology yeah
you're right that would literally be the
most valuable thing ever invented in
technology is it'd be like the guy who
invented was it Felker knows uh Silly
Putty right was invented by someone who
was trying to make an adhesive and like
he accidentally made oh this is
interesting
yeah why else that um I have to head off
obviously we could talk about this
forever and I feel like we barely
scratched the surface I also just wanted
to apologize that you know obviously
there's a lot of uh feelings about this
so sorry if we miss bits of information
I feel like people are probably going to
leave a bunch of stuff in the comments
so like updates or whatever it's
obviously a developing story as well I
also recorded this Thursday lunch yeah
I have no doubt there will be an update
uh tomorrow as well but yeah thank you
so much for joining us Robbie where can
people find you uh they can find me on
Twitter
um
underscore Rami but you can also just
find me Rami smile.com all my stuff is
there I write a newsletter for about
independent development if you want to
become an independent developer it's a
it's a place you could look uh I have a
bunch of video games that you should buy
but absolutely not installed just do not
do nothing stop thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it was an absolute
absolute pleasure
um what a weird time okay what a great
time we had uh my key and people know
where to find you it's fine yeah it's
fine don't worry about it should people
uh install your games
they should absolutely go and buy and
install uh Tron identity and then
uninstall it when they finish playing
please love that no don't even leave it
on there if they reinstall it because
they want to try again
yes leave it there forever never
uninstall anything never ever uninstall
and never upgrade do not upgrade your
devices
ever just
switch off your computer until we
already lets you know otherwise that's
the rule thank you all right thank you
all for watching see you next time bye
thank you
[Music]